all right so this is the talk of
Facebook YouTube pretty much the entire
Internet including about for porn sites
if you haven't heard by now some lady in
the UK was walking down the street and
saw cat and then looked over and saw a
garbage bin and just did the math and
thought the two would just be awesome
together and so she throws the cat in
the garbage bin [ __ ] and her first
explanation was get it he's just a cat
[ __ ]
then after the video went viral she was
like I'm sorry it was just a momentary
lapse of judgment I just thought it
would be funny so go head sit back and
relax while I explain to you why this
lady is indeed an [ __ ] other than the
obvious she threw a cat in a garbage bin
if you watch the video she approaches
the cat and and looks around to make
sure nobody's looking which throws a
wrench into her whole blood I don't get
it it's just a cat thing because she is
looking around to make sure she's not
gonna get caught throwing a cat in a
dumpster which means she recognizes that
it's a messed up thing to do and then
the next example is when she's about to
dump the cat oh wait wait for the car to
pass because we don't want anyone to see
you know cuz we're doing this would be
funny you don't want any witnesses when
you do something to be funny and then
the car passes then plop right in the
walk away really quickly because that's
how people walk when they don't think
they've done anything wrong yes walking
with haste the mark of the innocent I
mean give me a break don't even make
excuses just say it like it really is no
excuses I'm a sadistic [ __ ] what are
you gonna do I mean would that be any
worse people aren't gonna hate you less
you've already done it the four-year-old
cat was in the dumpster for 15 hours
before its owners followed the meows and
found it there so yeah the cat's alive
and well that still and the douchey lady
was identified at that point like I said
she was just all apologies she even
claims that she's a cat lover you know
like Michael Vick's a dog lover and OJ's
just a humanitarian I personally say we
turn her over to the professionals
I think this falls under code so I put a
link below showing the whole video in
this entirety go check it out and let me
know what you think of this comment
below about whatever this is Jeremy
saying not everyone's a douche bag but
that lady most certainly is
[Music]